Good Morning America I'm awake and I
want Troye Sivan to spit on me I was
about to say I'm into that but like whoa
whoa hey I'm Chris Vaughn and I'm gonna
be reading first tweets I saw the Shawn
Mendes one of these maybe laugh cuz I
wrote all of those tweets this was here
at yup how long's didn't user twice a
button okay fine look
I love Troye Sivan so much gosh choke me
hit me with the track that one's not
that bad thank you that's actually very
sweet I'm so glad I don't have a penis
cuz I would probably have a constant
burner because choice about it okay
I want choice' buns jawline to cut me
into fries like french fries Troye Sivan
more like lick honey off of me while
singing mary had a little lamb that's
like the most specific sexual fantasy
I've ever had in my entire life Mary
Troye Sivan could wrap me in duct tape
shave my head and throw me into a full
full of hot sauce from Taco Bell and I'd
still say thank you though I won't cry
Sivan two very you know I want Kosovo to
suffocate me with a wig why I want
closer than to set my house on fire and
extinguish it with something disgusting
I wish twice Devon can read my ass but
he's already a bottom not true but
whatever at Troye Sivan I want to lick
chicken off your nips cool my my my
a Troye Sivan needs to sit on my face
like right now tbh geez I'm more
embarrassed than the people in this room
that I am on the internet I feel like
really flushed I kind of love it
but reading it out loud like I'm so glad
that my mom didn't come to this shoot
[Music]